this is what dreams are made of this was
with dreams are made of
there seems to be more drama surrounding
Disney pluses Lizzie McGuire reboot this
time from Hilary Duff herself it's me
yeah take a look at this screen grab
from Hillary's Instagram story on
Tuesday night it's a picture of a
headline confirming the love Simon TV
show was pulled from Disney Plus for not
being family-friendly right above it
Hilary writes quote sounds familiar now
it's unclear if Hilary is saying that
the Lizzie McGuire reboot wasn't deemed
family-friendly enough or if she's
hinting that it's been pulled like love
Simon I want to like get everyone okay
while talking about it either way not a
great sign when the star of lizzie
mcguire shades the streaming service
where lizzie mcguire is supposed to air
guess I'll be going now I think it's
really gonna be fun to go on on the
journey with her at 30 and you know it's
the same Lizzie but she's an adult I
have that muscle memory of that like
awkward frantic kind of teenager it's
definitely fun and a little challenging
and also so familiar at the same time
this all comes a month after Disney Plus
confirmed that the creator and executive
producer of the show had left the reboot
after shooting just two episodes in
January a Disney spokesperson told et
quote fans have a sentimental attachment
to Lizzie McGuire and high expectations
for a new series after filming two
episodes we concluded that we need to
move in a different creative direction
and are putting a new lens on the series
we also learned at the time that the
show is being put on hold while they
looked for a new showrunner
et was the first to break the news that
a lizzie reboot could happen you you've
recently said that you would love to
revisit lizzie mcguire it's been over 15
years since the movie came out have
there been any conversations yes yes and
since then she's shared a ton of details
with us she has gained a lot of
confidence and she has a really cool
career and you know she's still I think
she's still gonna be faced with
challenging things we're in middle
school those challenging things seemed
funny and simple but relatable at the
time and I think now in your 30s it's
gonna be the same way but it's like
slightly heavier slightly bigger things
to deal with like she doesn't have kids
yet and she you know she there's some
surprises in the first episode that I
also don't want to give away animated
Lizzy does she have an updated look
she's gonna stay the same yeah which i
think is the right thing to do right
it's like that pink top it's so iconic
and like pop form flip flops
yeah those like rocket dog flip flops I
don't know if anyone knows those I think
she's really gonna be a lot of the comic
relief in the show alright guys that's
it for today what do you think Hillary
meant with her Instagram story is the
Lizzie reboot doomed I hope not but let
me know and for all the latest on Lizzie
and Hillary stick with all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now